[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Mad Dog Russo you can hear him on
SiriusXM channel 82 and also you can see
him on high heat MLB Network Mad Dog
Unleashed every weekday at uh three
Eastern and starting this Monday
uh oh Super Bowl trivia is back Chris
this drives you crazy why do you keep
punishing yourself
ah it's a good den always a pleasure to
know how much I love you yeah it does
because they never get these Dopey
questions right and and not only that
you got to give them an audio as a
number four I mean after all you're
giving them two great tickets to the
Super Bowl four nights in L and in a
Super Bowl City you got to make them
work for it and they never get the Audio
I mean remember we do our own audio so
it's not like you can look up a UPA UPI
or an AP sound biting sort of match the
voice it's our audio we do the
interviews to make it a little trickier
so yes Dan I add the extra hour all week
which means I got a babble to four
o'clock seven o'clock instead of six
o'clock and I gotta go into the city to
do it I can't do it at home because you
can't have five million questions on top
of me when I'm trying to do it from my
third floor UPS up upstairs on the third
floor and I'm going to be sitting there
Friday at 6 40. trying to give away the
last trip so I have a brutal week next
week in store okay 100 correct give us a
a sense of the questions that you're
you're going to ask or you've already
asked yeah no I'm going to
oh you're
Ed are you ready yep
all right here we go
Dan from wait wait wait dan from L.A Dan
from New Milford what do you want me to
say you're from go ahead uh Ohio all
right Dan from Ohio welcome hey thanks
thanks first time long time
there you go all right here you go damn
here's your chance are you a um
uh are you a Niner Bengal fan who's your
favorite team uh Bengals growing up
Bengals grown up all right here question
one
who was the last running back
to be named Super Bowl MVP last running
back should be named Super Bowl MVP
I've asked it already it should be easy
uh um
I guess I would say Terrell Davis comes
tomorrow yes stop there okay stop there
stop there okay I always I always miss
the easy ones well that's a good one and
by the way Todd Fritz and the Fellas if
he gets the second one right get the NFL
theme music around because you always
play the NFL music when you get halfway
off okay question two
name that this is a good one
name the first hand from Ohio name the
first Super Bowl we're both starting
quarterbacks played college football in
the SEC
first Super Bowl
both starting QBs played college
football in the SEC it's a tough one
I'll give you a clue it was not the same
SEC School
different okay
you know both uh I'll give you another
clue
hola famous
because initially I thought uh name it
that Alabama you had quarterbacks
um Kentucky
that's a good question yeah it is
so the first Super Bowl where both the
quarterbacks played college football on
the SEC you're leaning in the right
direction with your first guess uh Super
Bowl uh I won't tell you what Super Bowl
number it was but you know the game you
know the players uh and um it's one
you're gonna say yeah you're right I
should have gotten that
how about
Fran Tarkington
that's correct who's the other one
uh snake Stabler
to just stop fire up the music fire up
some music this is Super Bowl 11 stable
Alabama Tarkington at Georgia remember
talking 10 in the late 50s Stabler uh
you succeeded name it as uh our buddy
Danny just said all right now get the
music Todd let's go let's go here we go
all right I get a trip to Arizona all
right I'm already going okay number
three
it get a little harder now Dan as we
move along okay number three name the
first quarterback
to have two career Super Bowl rushing
touchdowns
first QB
that have do they have to have two
career Super Bowl rushing touchdowns So
that obviously means it's a quarterback
who played multiple Super Bowls
[Music]
Brady always had these quarterback
sneaks
um
uh
and from Ohio is a good contestant he
got the second one as tricky first one
isn't easy haven't asked it that much
and here he is he's halfway home the
first quarterback to have two careers
Super Bowl rushing touchdowns Dan from
Ohio that is who
[Music]
Jim McMahon
Dan's smart he did a little homework
he's not calling on a cell phone driving
around Cincinnati you know I you can see
my hands are up you can see that I'm I
have no help you don't hear him pressing
but you but when you have members who do
that like yeah it drives me crazy yes it
drives the Marquee crazy when they're
pressing their computer buttons and they
make me ask the question for the 9
millionth time you are doing it at the
top of your head that's what a good
football trivia person does
first quarterback Daniel two Super Bowl
rushing touchdowns
you know
uh
uh Joe Montana yes damn yes wow
that is pretty damn good holy smoke I
gave you nothing I gave you nothing I
didn't get a hint on that one okay you
didn't I kept thinking you know
uh Elway or McMahon and uh what made you
guess that one Montana
I I died because that was the Bengals it
was against the Bengals and I didn't
yeah I didn't know if you we had just
talked about that game uh with the
Bengals in in Montana
all right so now this is the audio one
we don't have the audio is ready Todd
somebody's got to tell me if he's got an
audio already for you I never thought
Dan would get the number four no we
don't uh we don't have enough
okay so that is the sample size of what
you do now here is the key for the audio
without giving too much away you got to
look for a theme
so uh the the audience has to think okay
what is this
jerk gonna come up with this year with
the theme the game is in Glendale uh you
don't know who the participants in until
Monday so I can't play along there the
number was it Super Bowl 57 Dan I think
it's 57 is it not yeah no so you maybe
you come up with the number 57 so I know
what the theme is I'm not going to tell
you because then it gives it away and
then I won't be able to last if I need
content but you get the idea and then
you gotta come up with the guys to
discuss the Super Bowl and then have
them figure out who it might be but the
fact that you got three is a tremendous
job
make them tougher next year mad dog okay
well the first one no no it's okay I'm
joking second one Dan
one is hard the second one was very hard
but I kept thinking okay who played you
know it was Tarkington and at first I
went wait Ole Miss
no he went to Georgia okay and then it
was Stabler okay Alabama okay that's
that was the the first SEC matchup that
I could think of with the two
quarterbacks so what made you think
about Davis
I took you know that's a long time ago I
was there
at the game yeah I was I was there uh
and you know what you know you know
what's funny about that first one I
wouldn't have guessed that because
that's 25 years ago now yeah
yeah wouldn't you have thought that they
would have been a running back in the
last quarter of a century that won an
MVP yeah
yeah well James White should have won it
when the Patriots beat the Falcons
they give it to Brady yeah yeah
uh yeah siriusxm.com 2023 Mad Dog trivia
for official rules with Mad Dog's show
uh we're talking to Chris Mad Dog Russo
just got into the Hall of Fame uh I've
I've listened the last couple of days
and it feels like you can't stay away
from Scott Roland that topic of going
into the Hall of Fame
and this is this feels like and I agree
with you on this this feels like the
baseball writers are going this get re
get used to this this is what we're
going to factor in on the new Hall of
Fame candidate if if Scott Roland just
went by the normal stats we had growing
up he's not a Hall of Famer but these
you know war and warp and all of this
other stuff Scott Roland's almost he's
going to be the poster child we're going
to look back and say that's when it
started and I agree with you Jeff cancel
Hall of Famer but if you don't want to
put him in then you can't put Scott
Roland in so we're on the same page with
this wow look at that yeah I
I mean
Roland and Kent Hannah only gets 46 of
the vote on his 10th year furthermore
doesn't it bother you Danny that in his
first year in 18 long only had 10 of the
voting yeah how do you go from 10 to in
in four years I don't understand has
that happened to anybody like what's the
lowest the lowest ever lowest ever and
what happens is the writer and one
writer told me hey you know what we just
didn't vote for Roland that first
go-round because we knew he wasn't going
to get in
I go well do you think he's a Hall of
Famer
well you didn't the first year but now
you do like what happened you just ran
out of good candidates this year I got
it Derek Jeter did Derek Jeter have 10
of the vote his first year of
Eligibility how about Mariano Mariano
have 10 of the vote did they say you
know what we got too many guys in the
ballot so let's make we won't vote for
Mariano this year 10 I can see if Roland
had 40 50 all right he made a jump
that's been done but Chris let me ask
you this what if I said you can either
look at all the stats
or you can't look at any stats
and you decide who's going into the Hall
of Fame so right now you can't factor in
anything with Billy Wagner other than
I'm going to go Billy Wagner Hall of
Famer
well I would say no because I would go
eye test and I'm going to remember the
bad games in the postseason okay uh Todd
Hilton
uh well I'm gonna I'm gonna be
anti-course field
because we all know that was a huge
Advantage you know galaraga and all
those daintante but [__] why isn't it
still an advantage Chris
say again I'm sorry we don't hear about
Coors Field being an advantage the way
it was when you had you know those those
great Rocky teams 100 percent
without looking at the stats doesn't it
bother you a little bit that Helton hits
287 lifetime outside of Coors Field and
he's got 140 homers yeah I mean
Hernandez at 296 and he's got 150 homes
put him in a Hall of Fame so I have a
problem with Hilton too and he's going
to make it look at his vote 71 yeah he's
going to get in yeah he's going to get
in but you know what I and we brought
this up Scott Roland wasn't a star
you know just a plug and play very good
Reds and Cardinals and you know whatever
you know Dale Murphy was a star Don
Mattingly star yes but they didn't have
the numbers but if you said hey Don
Mattingly's going in because of
contributions to the game or the star
power what he did you know he missed
probably two more years then he's going
to be a Hall of Famer Dale Murphy hits
400 home runs we might look at him
differently than 398 as crazy as that's
going to sound so we don't have star
power now how many uh how many players
would your kids go Dad I gotta go watch
him play Aaron judge
um
yep not many yeah but you trout trout I
don't know what I don't know I don't
think trout brings people out you don't
think so no no he's a great player he's
I understand what you're saying he's uh
but I here is basically what you're
saying is did Scott Roland ever sell a
ticket
I am did did my child who was a good
baseball fan did he say Hey Dad Roland's
in town can we go to a Met game at yank
at Citi Field to see Scott Roland
playing and the answer is absolutely not
and you know what the problem with the
Hall of Fame Dan is it's become the Hall
of Fame of the very good
it's not when you and I grew up it's not
the Hall of Fame of the great and or the
immortal you know what Bryce Harper
personality
Bryce Harper has star power there yes he
does and maybe that's not fair but I
I've maintained for a while now if you
have the Hall of Fame and you think of
it as Penthouse third floor second floor
first floor then I don't think we're as
offended if Scott Roland is in the first
floor and babe and all the other Legends
are at the penthouse and then maybe on
the third floor you have certain guys
second floor so you got in your first
floor when you go to you know
Cooperstown Scott Roland's over here and
you know whatever other guys you know
Bruce suter's over here it's not the
same you're in the building but it's not
the same that does that take away a
little bit of the well he's no Babe Ruth
or he's no Hank Aaron because I think
that's what bothers us like they're
going to be included in that Hall of
Fame class and they're they're guys who
shouldn't be yeah you and I are on the
exact same page you and I are on the
exact same page Roland's a very very
good player and I like this statistic
that I use this week how many balls do
you think think we're hit to roll and
they bring up they bring up the defense
and the Seven goal gloves how many balls
during a course of a week let's say
played six games that he gets that he
makes a play on that no other third
baseman in the sport makes a plan if
you're gonna tell me three that's a lot
because lots of times he doesn't get a
bull hit to him the whole game
so if you're going to tell me in six
games every other game he makes a play
at third base that not another third
baseman in the world can make a play on
let's say I be fair to you and I'll give
you three how many at bats does he have
during a week six games somewhere
between 24 and 28 at bats so he's got 24
to 26 at Bat Say and he gets three balls
hits you would you rather have the guy
that can make the maybe the three Place
ground balls or would you rather have
the who's who's better there would you
rather have the guy who's the better
offensive player who's got 23 more
chances to get up to the plate to get a
big hit I'd rather have the offense
myself would you wouldn't you rather
have the offense in well in today's game
absolutely
and and that's where Kent lines in all
right we understand he's not as good as
Ronald defensively he's got more homers
he's got more RBIs he's got more runs
scored he's got uh 10 points better
batting average and he won an MVP yeah
which woman never did and a tougher
ballpark to hit him too very good point
I was just going to bring that up and
and that boy good job Dan in that
ballpark with LA and San Diego and those
oh God drove me nuts I gotta I'll tell
you right now it's funny
the writers think they are changing the
way here but the only people that are
annoying are the old guys
my 20 year old doesn't care if Scott
Roland's in the Hall of Fame
the 50 year old does I know yeah I don't
know if it's his big a deal yeah I think
you know the 20 year old doesn't care if
bonds gets in or no it doesn't care no
it's not going to bother them but like
Manny and it bothered me that chilling
didn't get in because whether you like I
don't you know I don't like Jeff Kent's
personality
but that's not factoring into this I
love Dale Murphy's personality that
doesn't factor into this all I know is
certain guys you just go Kurt Schilling
was a Hall of Famer absolutely was
eleven and two in a postseason I'll tell
you somebody else that I've done a lot
on
that I think is a Hall of Famer that you
may have heard me say it that I am
shocked he's not in how is Steve Garvey
now we brought it up we we did 30
minutes on him uh two days ago he had 11
All-Star appearance I think he's got the
most All-Star he would be Robert Redford
not winning an Academy Award it's like
you know that guy over the course of his
he might have been just too good looking
Chris well I'll tell you something else
you know he played in 55.
post-season games
55. he had 228 bats you know what his
batting average was
3 38.
with 11 homers yeah now hone on that
here's the guy that won an MVP he had
200 hits he played in what 1400 games
before he broke his finger that year the
broke you know the slide of the plate he
he was a great postseason hitter he was
on iconic teams he played for 12 13
years in a row and this guy's not in the
Hall of Fame I mean and he played in a
big Market you know you would think that
playing in La that that would be reason
you know what how about we work on this
together you know what Steve Garvey
project we're going to get him in uh you
know I tell you right now he comes on
with me all the time because he knows I
go out there so when I need him he comes
down that's important
good luck with the trivia
what are you liking the games this
weekend by the way
well uh I just think the Bengals are uh
they're a really good team like good
solid team it's not Joe burrow
um that's a really good team and to be
back here knocking on the doorstep I I
like them I'd like the I like the road
teams I like the Niners I I just it
feels like that's the oh by the way
other game nobody talks about that game
everybody talking about Mahomes versus
burrow and that might be a better game
Niners versus the Eagles as far as you
know what you're not worried about
hurting on the road I am
I am but this is where I rely on Kyle
Shanahan he's got to coach him up all
you have to do is play average Dak
Prescott played below average and that's
why they lost if he plays average they
win that game I agree with you but if
you and I are on the same page all day
who would have thought who would have
thought you know when I spent 15 minutes
together and we're thinking along the
same way as today God what happened to
my career what's going on here I'm
that's a good point you better double
check where you're going if you're agree
with me Dan and the dog
yeah that'll be great you don't need my
Francesa I got you yes yes
you got all kinds of friends Stephen A
Smith you don't need anybody you've got
enough
oh he's a player you're the best thank
you Chris good to talk to you it will be
fun I'll be listening thank you buddy
Chris Mad Dog Russo